I bet you remember this gorgeous gown
the tailor wore in her wildest dreams
video that was the work of Christian
Siriano who is also designed dresses
forget this Oprah JLo Lady Gaga he's
also working with three stars for this
Sunday's Emmy any talk fashion but a
senior news editor Jennifer Paris what
have been your favorite red carpet looks
one of my first times I addressed
Christina Hendricks
for the Emmys was really amazing I think
I loved what Sarah Hyland wore to the
Emmys one year you know I loved what
Leslie Jones wore that was an amazing
moment that moment was when Leslie
needed a dress for her Ghostbusters
premiere christian stepped up and it
pretty much cemented his reputation as
the designer for women of every size it
takes a real designer to design for a
real woman i grew up my mom was a size
16 my sister was a size zero so to me i
never noticed that that was different
you never saw a difference I never saw a
difference I just was like oh my mom
loves a dress my sister loved to dress
Christian's New York Fashion Week runway
was one of the hottest tickets in town
last weekend wrapping up in time for him
to focus on dressing some of Hollywood's
biggest names for the Emmys this weekend
we're still getting requests you know
what it is where it is come on what
trends are you seeing for this award
season it's been very sexy lately like
everyone likes to show a lot of skin
which is very interesting what's it like
though I mean you designed something
that you're really proud of one of her
clients steps out on a red carpet and of
course there's haters out there that are
gonna criticize sometimes I will say
that the misses are not always my fault
bad shoe and hair makeup I do not get
that out of your control let me tell you
it drives me crazy I've had some ugly
hair with some of my clothes you just
take it and you you know luckily they'll
always be another red carpet